if there was an updated news about
Rick's status what would it be what's
the latest news about what's happening
with him you know we had to change cards
for legal reasons to what you see now
just a couple of weeks ago because he's
got a hearing on the 5th of December and
he in Fredonia is a very there's a
strong chance to be out on the 5th of
December but we can't we can't give a
date when he'll come out technically
it's 2020 so we just and we don't want
to be seen to be trying to influence the
outcome of the hearing Florida are very
touchy about it but he basically he
served
he's yeah so explain he served he's off
the life sentence but while he was
inside he's he's bothering his sister
got involved in the car stolen carring
and Rick put him in touch with somebody
in Florida so when they when they got
when they all got busted
Rick ended up taking the hit for his
sister and his mother who's already on
life about parole so he was like from
the president let's talk about wife so
the minute the minute Michigan let him
go for this floor this and a bus up to
connect him that was his freedom was
going from Michigan to Florida and a bus
yeah but when you speak to him now he's
like like he said in the phone call I
see you know when I first met him he was
resigned to dying in prison no he was
thought when you submit him he's like he
was when I first met him he gave me the
sense of tone for the film because he's
an incredibly funny guy and he's just
funny and he's like he is the glass
half-full kind of guy that he's dad was
he's got it but the optimism he's like
hope and and but he was resigned to
dying inside and when things have
changed now when you speak to him it's
like I fought he was like fun funny
before but now he's just you know he can
see light at the tunnel one is he's like
four years fine I can do this I don't
care he gets to see the ocean what was
the story that you wanted to tell and
how did your meetings with Rick change
the story that you thought you wanted to
tell well I was actually off sent when I
was
looking for projects and I was I said I
put to development and and I'm one of
the articles I've I came across I was
looking at all kind of things aren't
because but one of them was a activist
article for about white boy Rick and it
was fascinating article but I passed on
it ultimately did not go it was offered
to me but I just decided not to pursue
the rights because I couldn't see a
story that I heard that I made a
personal connection with it was not an
incredible informant story an
interesting the drug dealer story but
he's not kingpin I mean he was never he
was a dump kid I mean but I didn't make
a personal connection to it I just felt
you know I just did a movie in it and
then I but a year later I was sort of
spec scripts and they were I was all
white boy Rick I'll read that Jon Lester
and Jeff robinov I was really working
with Jon Lester on something else like
yeah I definitely read that cuz I know
that I read the article I be interested
to see what they've done with it and I
loved the father-son relationship but
that was only in it for like four or
five scenes and then it became this sort
of voiceover led us you know
Scorsese an aspiring kind of drug
dealers informant story about the wild
ride and I was like I do we connect same
actually I was like well I'd be really
interested in exploring to see if I can
make such a Jeff and John if I can
develop with the sort of father and son
story all the - all the way through so
we can take the voice-over out that
existed and see if the their
relationship could be what binds is that
becomes a fruit on the spine of the film
and I started I was doing it for two or
three months and I just couldn't make
headway with it because just so much
story and we didn't have at that point
we didn't have the rice to the article I
get a phone call from Scott Franklin who
works with Darren Aronofsky he slipped
right her man Perdue so he said yeah and
I found the project for us because me
and Taryn been talking about finding
something to do together I was like what
is it he's like the white boy Rick
project I was like you
you're kidding right I've been on it for
a few months it's like you can't you
can't be I've got life rights
so what says like this three of them out
there and I was like look I can't you
know he said was to we're not speaking
to Jeff Robin off and john nation
jeffrey went to make the films that look
the only way i can see for is if any way
I could make a personal connection to it
is the theme of an outsider and the
father-son relationship that I've got a
personal way into and I care about it
like it's a story about my own and I
could go with it but I need access I
need to speak to Rick to see if there is
a real movie in that and and in order to
happen I think we need to merge the two
projects so we we talked about merging
them and then so I went to see Rick I
like the cute up met him has been four
or five hours of him and I mean I think
for him at that point he'd been in 27
years no but and no one had asked him
about family when I started asking him
about his family was like what that you
want to talk about this and that I was
like well I've read the article I saw
here about your sister your father
grandparents and then he became really
emotional and it was an incredible four
or five hours just flew by and I got a
sense of Deer mush you know emotionally
how the emotional story and I and then I
was like okay I want to do this so we we
brokered a marriage between the two
projects one of the ways that you have
to find your way through the story is to
find an actor who's gonna play Rick and
I suspect it took a long time to find
Richie could you talk about the process
what you were looking for and how you
knew you found it when you met with
Richie okay it was a it was like a year
and a half two year process straightaway
as soon as I we started to prepare I was
like we should start to search now cuz
I've done this before
a show called top boy I did for channel
4 and I had like 38 non-actors in it and
I was very particular urban London urban
story or even some of the kids in 71
when the writers I was like we should be
stopped two-pronged attack to find our
Rick we should be looking at real actors
or or you know train kids
and non-actors so Francine Mazur came on
board to be the main cast and I returned
and we approach to life event that he
had done he'd cast American honey which
I thought was wonderfully Street cast
and they work together and Francine
almost every actor you can imagine from
here to Australia UK I'm serious like it
like everywhere - on tape and I met a
lot of them and Jennifer cleaned the
streets in various states I've met a
couple actors to turn my head they were
amazing but they ultimately 19 20 and I
just didn't want this to have to like
pretend you know you want to see a 14 15
year-old boy in in it in the film you
know I thought was important and also
that you could tell I feel like the kids
I was seeing hadn't hadn't lived around
african-american kids you know it just
felt appropriate than the kind of you to
be waiting so Jennifer went into
Baltimore they went to one of these
particular high schools where it's
pretty mixed and a bit rough and she she
talks to a principal and and he kind of
heard about about street casting because
you know they'd cast a lot of the wire
was done that way so bottom was not
unfamiliar with that process and as they
were walking out the principal's office
does this kid waiting because he was in
trouble he was like what you can you can
start with this kid here they didn't
really like him and that's Richie who's
in the film when you get Ritchie cast he
obviously hasn't acted before what does
that mean about getting somebody who's
young in terms of whatever his family
situation is to get him on set for
probably a couple months of rehearsals
and then shooting and then working with
somebody like Matthew how do you break
that down for somebody who's never done
that professionally and how do you ease
him into that so he's not feeling
overwhelmed yeah I mean it's a process
it's a big ol thing he was rough is raw
I really were yeah you know behavioral
issues do we want do anything dance that
way it was I met with him
it came to Cleveland to me me I like I
can't loved him anyway as a kid I didn't
know if you could do it I'll put him on
tape a couple of things I was like okay
I could see something here so it's a my
field look you know I'm figuring using a
non actor I'm a few loved that idea he
was open you know you have to remember
he was street cast you know who his cast
out of a bar you know
faizon confused he wasn't he was a known
actor he was the non actor on the set
that was only supposed to say three
lines and they got a kick out of him so
he next thing you know these parts that
was kept growing every day you know to
bring the kid back so he had he had a
generosity of spirit towards the kid
towards the idea but he wasn't we
weren't we were being careful not to be
hopefully you know hope is he romantic
about it because you'd have to find
someone likely put it off so anyway we
brought math we brought the kid out to
do a workshop with Matthew I spent the
whole day we worked scenes we and it was
just what was incredible to watch was
the effect a how Matthew was with the
kid and be the effect it had on Matthew
because Matthew could come in hop and
had ideas but you know he quickly
relayed him look you know he can't be in
a Matthew McConaughey film because he
doesn't he can't act
you have to be in this or you're gonna
be he's gonna have to be in his film and
and Matthew just got that and he loved
it and the kid saw anchored him so he'd
have to like tap-dance around what the
kid was doing and cheering into the kids
frequency and convinced us that he's the
kid's father you know and the way he was
pitching things the kid was fascinating
it's quite enigmatic and but you know
there's a inner life he access a lot of
he could access a lot of a mission
emotion because he's been abandoned and
stuff so his own life in some ways
touched
Rick's on yeah yeah so then when we cast
him it was there was a boot camp I got
him out of we needed I knew I needed to
spend some months of him before shooting
it was going to be a long shoot
because if I took him on I didn't cast a
17 or 18 year old boy I will only get
eight-hour days which means I need more
days so he's going to be a long shoot we
and very short days and I'd have to get
him ready for the marathon so we needed
a chaperone free surprise so this
extraordinary thing happened to a place
on the set on the shoot because I was
making a father-son story with him and
Matthew and then which looking for a
chaperone there was no one in his family
could do it you know they're really poor
family and the only one could take time
off the work to chaperone him he didn't
want to come with a higher chaplain from
Studio you didn't he'd never left he'd
never left his state before right so he
was so the blue his mother says she'll
do it and he hadn't lived with his
mother his mother left him left when he
was four years old
they'd been out of contact more or less
for more than a decade go through you
know rehab and stuff and having a very
difficult life and his older brother was
in jail so it's all your finger was
taking place where there was like we're
making a father/son film and behind the
scenes is like his mother and daughter
mother and son reconciliation taking
place and yeah and he came we got him
three months before when I changed his
diet and we give him coaching lessons
and Matthew was like Matthew would hang
out with him a few would take him under
his wing he'd go bowling with him maybe
and I'd have to be more the paternal
figure and he would be like he's in the
movie but he'd be his buddy if the kid
misbehaved he wouldn't tell him to
behave he just like he'd get involved
which was a bit painful at times but did
the kid even know who Matthew was no but
to say that I mean that was that was the
most extraordinary bit like you turn
nothing that I you just didn't know
Matthew McConaughey was how even the
fourth GU being just didn't just not
culturally on his radar whatsoever it
was amazing so he's completely unfazed
me ma'am yeah and thank you so much for
coming and sure you're filming us